hey reject nation I'm Greg Alba on our
patreon we do TV show reactions for many
shows as well as weekly Q&A is one of
our reward tiers is whatever video your
request we must definitely cover usually
it is a reaction and today comes from a
lovely gentleman named Eric Horstmann
been talking this gentleman quite a bit
we share a lot of love and enthusiasm
for horror movies especially guy lives
all the way in Atlanta right now he's
always making cracks about his age as if
he's like some senior citizen I'm
looking at your photo right here and you
look like one handsome serial killer
oh gosh you got like that serial killer
traits where I'm like wow I I think
you're charming you're good-looking but
you have hints of a serial killer Eric
my kind of friend so I can't wait to
kick it with you one day buddy just me
you and Lisa let's see what happens to
her at the end of that night no no Eric
won't kill you okay he wants us to watch
the date top 10 celebs who can't stop
laughing and who likes to laugh Lisa
likes to laugh and that's that's what
makes for a great reaction video laugh
when in doubt laugh it out there we go
[Laughter]
so I
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
seriously these guys make me want to be
famous these guys make me want to be
famous
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
I used to write I wrote a poem about her
and like kind of great yeah I have a
dilemma over you oh my god
is it a rap you can make it into a rap
never claimed to know how to rap I wish
they would show us why they're laughing
them I know meets you cuz I'm not yeah
but laughing is very contagious the
other ones I kind of did though this one
we have no way to know why she's
laughing
oh just try she's talking to me
something
I don't think Elijah I can see him oh
you can't
satellite in my upsetting oh my god is
easy to break to school which you need
but pretty boy start to meet at you all
over the budget drip stay continued miss
wine in the house what you never buy a
car in a coma
having a period that I haven't seen but
I think I heard that happens I haven't
seen the movie but I think she's
describing like this and they say
seriously bring our hands together sirs
and I think important serious
there's rushing energy about family
dynamics
and I and I appreciated the work you did
it as a producer and as an actress thank
you very much very much sir
a big ball that's a baseball movie
Moneyball
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
however a lot of it on our end right now
I love this order it's a skull they
can't stop laughing
yeah I've seen this actually he's always
laughing at ya Jimmy paws I'm okay of
course the specific clip makes me this
is like a full ten minute clip this one
really yeah oh man I love this book I
was in so many times
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
so many times well you're welcome you're
welcome I watched that clip
the woman Bradley Cooper on my own like
twice and I just kept laughing because
that's like a ten minute clip and it's
funny because what they're what's
happening is he's trying to promote this
play that he's in and it's based on a
true story of a guy who actually died I
can't stop because I did this bit with
these hats they're trying to have this
smooth transition where they have to
keep the hats on because of continuity
but they can't stop laughing nice and
then I show it to John and he really
laughed a lot yeah I showed it to my
girlfriend and she hates Bradley Cooper
so she didn't laugh which was a bummer I
watched the whole ten-minute video I'm
just like together
there are times sometimes you're getting
together with people and you have no
idea what they're laughing at sometimes
you're just sitting there and kind of
smiling because you don't really know
what to do yeah you know for most
situations it does end up being
contagious and you just laugh anyway it
doesn't matter what's going on laughter
it can be very contagious and I have
heard crying and laughter it's funny
they feel like they're two opposite but
they're actually kind of
linked in some ways but cry and cry as
you laugh yeah exactly
the best emotional medicines you could
have is those two right there I remember
when I was really young and I saw
actually if we can find that clip
Gweneth Paltrow laughing hysterically on
Conan O'Brien that was my favorite sure
she just couldn't stop laughing laughing
it doesn't even matter does it she did
some like terrible British accent and
just made her laugh forever it's just
all dissolved you have a talk in England
about this movie and I'll tell you why I
had know nothing about the movie I heard
that you had a new movie coming out they
sent me to a screening and I knew
absolutely nothing I feel so happy for
the people like the one with Chloe grace
Moretz or Adam Levine or Emilia Clarke
yeah these are press junkets they're in
that room for hours and they got like
interviewers coming in and out getting
asked the same question over and over
and over again so if you could be that
interviewer who gets them cracking up
and like enjoying the interview that
much winning that's gold for them that's
gold for your interview and that must
make the interviewer feel really good
yeah you can if you can have a highlight
in that person's life for that day you
know making that famous person laugh
after their probably bored out of their
mind for answering the same questions in
a row tation all day you know even
though it's a top ten list and I could
see why the Bradley Cooper ones at
number one my favorite ones the Matthew
McConaughey one because that really was
funny he's asking him a question about
have you guys worked together before and
they didn't how to Lose a Guy in ten
days before they did the film that
they're promoting there and he's like
have you guys worked together before
interviewers do your research before you
do ask these questions you know yeah I
can be pretty embarrassing if you really
don't know what you're talking about
interviewing these people especially
when there's someone who's that famous
you should know what you're talking
about it's these kind of celebrities
that I just love there's there something
about specifically a famous person you
admire cracking up that brings the most
joy when there's that famous it's like a
stranger to video I'm like whatever but
if you're famous I'm like yeah
but if you're famous I'm like you're
human and that's why I love you
I want it what if they're not famous but
you do know them that doesn't matter to
me means nothing okay you could laugh
all day and it won't make a difference
okay as displayed in this video oh yeah
yeah you mean nothing
right until you're famous then I worship
you at your feet
I love celebrities yeah who's your
favorite favorite just celebrity I think
when it comes to interviews that my
favorite person to watch is Ryan Gosling
because he has this yeah I mean he's my
he's one of my favorite actors of all
time but in terms of like interviews of
just watching celebrity interviews oh
and Conan O'Brien watching Conan O'Brien
be interviewed and watch but watching
Ryan Gosling be interviewed cuz he's so
cool and swab but he's also so funny at
the same time yeah he's just everything
no really it's a really sad insecure
fact about my life I'd rather be Ryan
Gosling here okay who's your favorite
celebrity do you know Ross Matthews oh
yeah Tonight Show he's that he's really
flamboyant energetic nice yeah like I
don't know him personally but I've
interviewed him before yeah oh nice and
funny I read his book so there you go
you found your favorite celebrity okay
there we go
Ross Matthews yeah he's hilarious great
he is great we have learned our favorite
celebrities with that in mind thank you
so much - Eric Horstmann recommending
that I hope you keep on laughing buddy
because you need to develop that evil
serial killer laugh for when you're
doing your activities guys you can
subscribe to the reject nation yeah
click that notification bell yeah yeah
and check the sign up a tree oh my god
TV show reactions acute street ah and
Lisa Mallory tree oh I'm sorry using
that turn your Patriot oh oh that's good
it's too good now you're gonna use it's
okay check her out on Instagram and
YouTube people die